president-elect joe biden is calling for
unity and healing
as america moves forward into our
national future
i'm just kidding he's trying to start a
race war no one can tell me
that it had been a group of black lives
matter protesting yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very differently
than the mob of thugs that stormed the
capitol
we all we all know that's true and it is
unacceptable
totally unacceptable the american people
saw a plain view
and i hope it's sensitized into what we
have to do i think joe actually has a
point had it been blm they probably
would have been treated differently
they would have been permitted to burn
down the building and then kamala harris
would have raised money for their bail
funds
if passed as precedent we'll get into
all of it i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from drummer 703 who
says
we don't know all the facts but we do
know that this is worse than watergate
this is worse than watergate
absolutely true because most things are
worse than watergate i would say almost
almost everything is is worse than
watergate
because i watch cnn so that's that's
what i have been
told you know so few things
are outside the realm of politics these
days i think maybe the the last one that
is
are your pets so you gotta go check out
petsmart great way to keep your pets
happy and keep you happy
especially during this pandemic you can
order from
from home you can go pick up curbside
delivery really terrific from the
beginning of the pandemic petsmart has
remained open making sure you can get
everything your pet needs
right when you need it at over 1600
convenient locations
petsmart stores and grooming salons
offer digital check-in
curbside drop off and pick up and
contactless payment
and now petsmart offers free same-day
delivery
powered by doordash through january 31st
so that you can get everything your pet
needs right to your door and right when
you need it
petsmart's associates really love pets
and caring for them is a big part of why
they work there
petsmart has made it safe and easy for
you to care for your pet to online or in
stores
if you're interested in contactless
shopping you just order online
at petsmart.com or on the petsmart app
you can enjoy easy curbside pickup
or free same day delivery powered by
doordash
go check it out right now petsmart is
not just pet friendly that would be good
enough
but because of their great prices and
service they are very human friendly
as well check out petsmart.com for more
details
does this guy think we're stupid he does
i guess he does think that we're stupid
does he think that we don't remember the
last
six months when blm was permitted
to burn down sometimes government
buildings more often private buildings
to loot basically with impunity very few
people went to prison
and the few people that did go to prison
what happened joe biden's vice president
posted a fundraiser for their bail fund
so yeah probably they would have been
treated a little differently
had it been blm or antifa rather than
some trump supporters at the capitol a
couple of days ago
joe biden does this all the time though
you're going to hear the calls for unity
and healing
and it happens in the same breath
they'll say half the country is
deplorably irredeemable neo-nazis we
need
healing and unity all these people
should be kicked off of social media and
not allowed to go back to their jobs
unity and healing and it's this this
endless endless cycle
but it's with biden especially he tries
to put this focus
on race you know if you really believed
that the people who stormed the capital
are neo-nazi white supremacists
they represent 70 million neo-nazi white
supremacist americans
who are on the verge of a civil war
that is largely on racial grounds if you
really believed that
would you then try to stoke racial
tensions no
of course not joe biden doesn't think
we're on the verge of a civil war
joe biden just thinks stoking racial
tensions
is a good way to score political points
he's been doing it for a long time do
you remember
what was it eight eight nine years ago
now when joe biden
said that mitt romney met romney
as milc toast a liberal squish
republican
as you can possibly find such a liberal
squish
he invented obamacare such a liberal
squish that when he was running for
senate against teddy kennedy
he disavowed ronald reagan and george
bush
that guy so squishy but even he
nevertheless wanted to put black people
back in chains
according to joe biden look at what they
value
and look at their budget and what
they're proposing romney wants to let
the
he said in the first hundred days he's
gonna let the big banks once again write
their own rules
unchain wall street
they're gonna put you all back in chains
wants to put you all back in chains uh
unity and healing
yeah mitt romney every single republican
to the right of mitt romney namely
all of them and some democrats too yeah
they they support slavery yeah vote for
me unity and healing
joe biden is not the only one who is
doing this nancy pelosi
doing this as well president trump has
what like 12 days or something left in
his
term nancy pelosi is calling to remove
the president
immediately through the 25th amendment
yesterday the president of the united
states
incited an armed insurrection against
america
the gleeful desecration of the u.s
capitol
which is the temple of amer of our
american democracy
and the violence targeting congress are
horrors that will forever stain
our nation's history instigated by the
president of the united states that's
why it's
such a stain in calling for this
seditious
act president has committed an
unspeakable assault
on our nation and our people
i joined the senate democratic leader in
calling on the vice president
to remove this president by immediately
invoking the 25th
amendment if the vice president and
cabinet do not act
the congress may be prepared to move
forward with impeachment
that is the overwhelming sentiment of my
caucus
oh well the overwhelming sentiment of
your caucus
and a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee because that's not the purpose of
the 25th amendment and
absolutely mike pence is not going to
invoke it the 25th amendment
is a procedure for the removal of the
president should he be incapacitated
unable to discharge the duties of his
office
president trump is discharging the
duties of his office just fine
i know that nancy pelosi is very upset
about this but there is
absolutely talk about upsetting
constitutional norms and historical
precedent
there is absolutely no justification for
invoking the 25th amendment but then did
you hear what she says
at the end at the very end she says if
not we're going to move forward with
impeachment
you people already tried that and it
didn't work because it was a completely
ginned up charge
over nothing and it was the
fifth iteration of the coup d'etat that
democrats had been trying to launch
since trump was campaigning and the
obama administration was spying on him
illegally after that they try to
well for one they colluded with a
foreign power namely russia to put
together this bogus steel dossier
to continue their legal assault on trump
didn't go anywhere mueller investigation
didn't go anywhere
they cook up this ukraine thing didn't
go anywhere
they ignored the legitimate corruption
in ukraine from president-elect joe
biden
still doesn't go anywhere why would they
want impeachment
if if you really believe that that half
of this country supports donald trump
and donald trump's a nazi so therefore
half the country is a bunch of nazis
if you really think they're ready for
armed insurrection that's what they keep
calling this
do you really think it will help the
cause of unity and healing
to to impeach and convict the president
of the united states still popular with
his base
a dozen days before he's supposed to
leave office
no that will not heal a wound that will
exacerbate it that will
that will rip open a scab won't it
what would be the point of that well one
the democrats are hoping
to provoke the right so that they can
have further justification to clamp down
they're already doing it
they're de-platforming conservatives
in a very large scale which we'll get to
in a second
there's another procedural aspect to
this as to why the house would try to
impeach president trump
assuming assuming he only gets this one
term
president trump can still run again in
four years
and president trump has intimated that
he might run again in four years
if he is impeached and convicted he
can't run again in four years and so
there actually is
a long-term political benefit for
democrats if even though
you know as a practical matter right now
he's not going to do anything in 10 days
but in the long term if they impeach and
convict him and right now they might
have the political will to do it
because a bunch of squishy republicans
are going to blame trump for
every evil that befalls the country and
they're going to they're going to blame
trump for the riot at the capitol and
they're going to completely ignore blm
and the
six months of rioting that burned down a
bunch of the country but they're just
going to focus on this one act as the
as the sole aspect of political violence
in the country even though frankly it is
a relatively
minor aspect given what we saw in 2020
still bad still unacceptable but
relatively
smaller than what we saw for the rest of
the year
and they'll try to convict him and that
way he won't run again
and what this says to me is they still
fear the guy
even after all of this after trump's
self-inflicted wounds and there have
been many of them
and after every attack the democrats
have tried to lobby on him
they still fear this guy they fear that
he has a constituency
that the establishment republicans do
not
i think they they feel somewhat
similarly about josh hawley i think
that's why they're going after him
i think they feel similarly about ted
cruz i think that's why they're going
after him
they are trying to
prevent
voices that they you know they talk very
kindly about how we all need to come
together and unify
they don't want to do that they want to
marginalize voices
not just the fringy voices not just the
bigoted voices
they want to marginalize mainstream
conservatives and they are
doing that and you've got elite people
getting in on the act
michelle obama michelle obama former
first lady
always there's always chatter that she's
going to run for office herself
she came out released a statement
calling for the deep platforming
of president trump on social media
there are a lot of calls for president
trump they say
kick him off of twitter or kick him
off of facebook or take away the phone
or something but we hadn't heard it from
someone at the level of michelle obama
now they're all trying to do it and do
you think they're just going to kick
trump off
or do you think they're going to kick
you off and me off
i know a lot of conservatives are saying
their twitter followers have decreased
mine has decreased a lot i just i only
because i saw it was
going around the internet i looked i
said oh gosh yeah it's down in thousands
i i assume this is because social media
are
already purging many of these
conservative accounts
trump had this line in the campaign he
said they're not coming after
me they're coming after you and i just
happen to be in the way i think we're
about to see this proven true because
michelle obama can come out and call for
trump to be kicked off of social media
and do you know what happens even the
duly elected sitting president
facebook heeds the call
michelle obama calls for trump
to get kicked off and mark zuckerberg
says absolutely
michelle obama's statement is very wordy
as the obamas
are want to be you can read barack
obama's third memoir i think it's only
800 pages right now
so i'll skip around a little bit obama
talks about how
she is so happy that that radical
socialist raphael warnock won
election in georgia because he's going
to be george's first black senator
first socialist senator too i think then
first senator whoever hosted fidel
castro to church that's well
big wonderful history isn't it
then in just a few hours my heart had
fallen harder and faster than i can
remember
like all of you i watched as a gang
organized violent and mad
they'd lost an election laid siege to
the united states capital
oh terrible did she watch blm over the
summer not sure she did
oh no she did because she gets to it
later in her letter
this summer's black lives matter
protests were an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement oh my
gosh
our nation's largest demonstrations ever
bringing together people of every racing
class encouraging millions to re-examine
their own assumptions
and for those who call others
unpatriotic for simply taking a knee in
silent protest for those
who wonder why we need to be reminded
that black lives matter at all
you know nobody nobody needs to be
reminded of that yesterday made it
painfully clear
that certain americans are in fact
allowed to denigrate the flag and
symbols of our nation
they've just got to look the right way
so michelle obama also stoking all these
racial tensions which she did for her
entire public career as well
she makes the claim that black lives
matter is overwhelmingly peaceful
i guess i'm willing to grant that i mean
they did
torch cities coast to coast for a very
long time
uh but sure i of the people who say that
they support black lives matter i
suppose it's a small percentage you get
violent right
and yet she says that here these trump
supporters
are violent thugs a gang
criminals she doesn't seem to
afford the trump supporters quite the
same grace that she affords to black
lives matter
even though it just is a simple matter
of numbers
the trump supporters are much much much
much much incomparably more peaceful
than black lives matter has been
both in the riot even at the ride on the
capitol
compared to the torching of cities for
six months
but but also just more broadly blm
has come out they are a an explicitly
marxist organization
they say they want to disrupt the entire
society right down to including
the nuclear family and they've used
violence
repeatedly lots of blood on the hands of
blm
she won't afford them the same the same
grace
she won't afford trump trump supporters
the same grace and then she says
here's the key now is the time for those
who voted for this president to see the
reality of what they've supported and
publicly and forcefully
forcefully rebuke him and the actions of
that mob now is the time for silicon
valley companies to stop enabling this
monstrous behavior
and go even further than they have
already done
by permanently banning this man from
their platforms and putting in place
policies that prevent their technology
from being used
by this nation's leaders to fuel
insurrection insurrection
blm mostly peaceful protest the right at
the capitol
insurrection which justifies the
censorship of the sitting president
himself
facebook caved by the way but
but even before we get into that because
i think that's the great threat that
we've got to look at
for the next several years i want to
address this point that some people
are talking about on social media in the
commentary
a lot of conservatives are pointing as
as am i doing right now
a lot of conservatives are pointing out
the double standard on the blm riots
right so we're saying hold on the left
gets to burn down the country for six
months that's called mostly peaceful
then a group of these rioters who are
right-wing rioters mostly mostly
right-wing riders
go to the capitol and
this is the worst event in the history
of the united states
it's a bad event but how come one of
them how come one of those six month
long
insurrections is absolutely totally fine
wonderful
american is apple pie but then the rowdy
riot at the capitol that's the worst
event in our history it's like pearl
harbor all over again
what they're saying the left is saying
is that this is an example of
what a baptism we're talk guys we're
talking about the trump
capital riot right now we're not talking
about blm
right that's what that's the point i'm
making we should be talking about blm
because it's a ridiculous double
standard and i'm not going to stand for
it
well no now you're engaging in what a
baptism what these people don't seem to
understand maybe they do and they're
just being cynical about it
most accusations of what a baptism
are themselves examples of what a
baptism
what i mean by that is what a baptism
for those who haven't heard this word
endlessly over the past several days and
weeks is when
someone accuses you of doing something
and then you bring up something that
they have done
in response rather than dealing with the
accusation they're making
now in this case
we're saying there is political violence
in this country and it's the trump
supporters
it is not what a baptism to come out and
say well actually
the the riot at the capitol follows six
months of
nationwide political violence by the
left which was actually
encouraged not just by these crazy
fringe people on the ground but
encouraged by elected democrats and
members of the media
while the riot was going on trump was
telling them to stop it and go down and
be peaceful
but while the blm riots were going on
the left leading leftists were
encouraging it
well that's what a baptism it's not what
a baptism when people bring up what a
baptism what they're saying is
it would be as though you began the
conversation from saying hey that blm
stuff is pretty bad
i'll say look we need to talk about what
a baptism well okay the whatabaptism
charge is the what a baptism
and i don't want to hear it because any
conversation
that any leading left-winger or
right-winger for that matter
wants to have about what happened at the
capitol if that conversation does not
include
the six months of egregious
nationwide political violence from the
left
that were going on right right up until
the election
and then the left won the election so it
went away if it does not include that
i don't want to have that conversation i
don't think that's a good faith
conversation
i don't think that's a good faith debate
i don't think any of these people
are playing in good faith and some some
republicans some conservatives are
falling for this trap
and it's absolutely pathetic because
it's going to get a lot worse and it's
going to affect everybody
facebook heeded michelle obama's call
they have now banned donald trump from
facebook and instagram
from zuckerberg quote we believe the
risks of allowing the president
to continue to use our service during
this period are simply
too great therefore we are extending the
block we have placed on his facebook and
instagram accounts
indefinitely and for at least the next
two weeks
until the peaceful transition of power
is complete
so big tech
in collusion with the liberal
establishment michelle obama
hard to get more liberal establishment
than that
is now banning censoring
the duly elected president nobody has
elected
michelle obama nobody ever elected
michelle obama i guess she was part of
the package with barack but he's not in
office anymore
nobody elected mark zuckerberg to
anything
the only person in this whole
circumstance who has been elected
through our constitutional process is
donald trump and he's the one being
censored at the behest of the others
it's not just the censorship on facebook
though
he's no longer allowed to engage in
commerce
shopify has banned president trump
his campaign any of his organizations
from using their service to process
payments
he's being the dually elected president
being ostracized from commerce they
write quote
based on recent events we have
determined that the actions by president
donald j
trump violate our acceptable use policy
which prohibits promotion or supportive
organizations
platforms or people that threaten or
condone violence to further a cause
as a result we have terminated stores
affiliated
with president trump
this is this is unprecedented this is
extremely dangerous much more historic
and dangerous than any of the events
that we've been talking about
really even over the last few months
they're not after him they're after
you and me and this is going to have
we've seen this happen to prominent
conservatives they just pick one off and
they say well hopefully we won't care
oh the circumstance is meredith they've
been trying to pick off trump now for
for four years five years and now they
think this is a good moment where we can
totally de-platform him and censor him
and you're going to hear squishy
conservatives say
well and i'm going to call them
conservatives squishy republican types
they'll say
well look trump can just make his own
e-commerce platform
well trump can make his own largest
social media network in the world
no no well we only care about government
censorship no if the god
if someone is completely ostracized from
society i don't care
if it's the government doing it or some
oligarchs in silicon valley doing it in
cahoots
with the liberal establishment that is
an
urgent problem
not just them in addition to
social media and e-commerce kicking off
president trump we now have simon
schuster major major publisher
canceling senator josh hawley's book
josh hawley was writing a book
coincidentally on big tech tyranny
and because josh hawley followed the
constitutional process
to object to some of the electors in
this election
because of election irregularities simon
schuster is canceling his book
on the unrelated topic of big tech they
write quote we did not come to this
decision lightly yeah okay
as a publisher it will always be our
mission to amplify a variety of voices
and viewpoints at the same time we take
seriously
our larger public responsibility as
citizens and cannot support
senator hawley after his role in what
became
a dangerous threat to our democracy and
freedom
what was josh hawley's role
josh hawley's role in the dangerous
threat toward by also what dangerous
threat toward democracy and freedom
the the riot at the capitol very bad
very ugly people are going to be
punished
as they should be this was not a coup
d'etat
this was larping this was a decadent
mob uh playing a live-action video game
they went in and took silly pictures in
nancy pelosi's office there was no new
constitution
there was no declaration of new
representatives they just went in
and messed up some stuff in the capital
and and left
the threat to our democracy what like
this is the russian revolution or
something give me a break
this is an excuse by simon schuster to
ban conservatives
what did hawley do did holly go out and
say because frankly if josh holly went
out there and said hey
we need to go storm the capitol right
now i actually could
understand the decision it's pretty bad
stuff you don't want to be associated
with that
that's not what he did he followed the
constitutional process
to challenge electors after an
unprecedented election
in which all of the safeguards of
election integrity were upended
weeks and maybe months before the
election we've never seen anything like
it
in certain cases in pennsylvania notably
in explicit violation of the state
constitution
yeah i think it's okay to object i think
it's okay to follow the legal process in
that case
nope not not according to simon
schuster well look michael if you
if you don't want if you want to read
josh hawley's book you already just
found your own publishing house
no this is so profoundly naive
it's the result of
years and years of right-wing
capitulation and buying into
a shallow sort of quasi-libertarian
argument
that the political realm is really
really small
and private people
ought to be able to do whatever they
want to do at any given time without any
restrictions
it's it's the result of a of a
fundamental misunderstanding of what the
founding fathers meant when they talked
about liberty
which they said time and time and time
again is not licentiousness
liberty is not just the ability to exert
our will however we want pursue our
appetites at any given time
regardless of justice
liberty true liberty is the
freedom to do what one ought to do
that is what liberty is lord acton
himself put it that way
if we live in a society where the laws
this they're basically okay
but we can't go to work
we can't go to church we can't
engage in any sort of commerce we can't
talk to anybody
[Music]
what kind what what are our rights well
no it's okay it's only shopify
infringing on it it's only facebook it's
only the people who control the public
square
they're the only ones infringing on it
it's fine right no i don't think so
shows you how inverted our understanding
of power is in this country
we think well we don't think this we i
think we know better
but the left what they pretend is donald
trump he's the ruling class he's the man
donald trump has barely any power and he
barely ever did
and he won his election in 2016 on a
fluke and they sure weren't going to let
him do it again
the liberal establishment is the ruling
class
big tech big media big
university right big education big
bureaucracy
you know the people who tried to subvert
the presidency for four years
all these institutions
that's the ruling power in this country
josh hawley doesn't have any power
donald trump barely has any power we
have this very inverted sense of things
you heard joe biden say well if it had
been blm
oh my gosh it would have been a massacre
blm burned the country down for six
months nothing happened to them
they were treated with far less harsh
policing
than the the right wing rioters were
kamala harris raised money for their
bail funds
you hear you often hear this is the
canard of the left that you hear when
they're race hustling you always hear
about
white privilege white privilege well
another crazy white lady has been
pretending to be
a different race now for years prominent
human rights attorney
has been posing her name is uh natasha
lycia
aura banan that's i guess the name she
goes by
she's been posing as a latina woman for
years claiming to be puerto rican and
colombian
she's not she's just a white lady so
weird
it's so weird how with all this white
privilege going around
you have this lady and rachel dolezal
and that other crazy lady who was a
professor and
all of these white people
pretending to be other races linda
sarsour
when she was asked why she put the hijab
on
linda sarsour is an islamist activist
linda sarsour said
because without the hijab i'm just
another white lady in new york
she tried to promote the creation of a
new racial grievance group called middle
eastern north african
or mena because historically arabs are
categorized as whites in the united
states
if there's white privilege wouldn't you
want to remain in the privileged group
maybe the privilege cuts a different way
but i have to tell you there is some
really good news we can't we can't leave
without
discussing this axe body spray
uh is uh condemning the violence act you
know the thing that like 12 year old
boys spray on themselves
acts says we'd rather be lonely than
with that mob axe condemns yesterday's
acts of violence and hate at the capitol
we believe that the democratic process
and the peaceful transition of power
uh are very important so glad they final
i was waiting with baited breath on them
frankly dunkaroo's silence on this topic
is deafening and it kind of weird how
the resistance
is uh includes all of corporate america
all of the educational institutions all
of the media
all of big technology all like everybody
isn't that weird how that's the
resistance
it's almost like they're not the
resistance almost like they're not
the resistance uh we have got to get to
mailbag first i should note though
actually the biggest news of the day
president trump uh came out he's
condemned
the ride at the capitol he
has said that he thinks there was
a lot of election irregularity he's not
saying this is stolen he's just saying
that it was very very unfair
but he is saying that he will uh commit
to the peaceful transition of power
it was an excellent uh speech he had he
had to give the speech
it was very presidential it i think
allays any fears that he should be
removed through the 25th amendment or
impeachment or anything like that
and he says he might be back and maybe
that's why nancy pelosi is going to try
to impeach him too
they're going to heal and unify as best
they can and they're going to muscle
trump
to do it you know there's a reason why
the media create narratives about
conservatives it has to do with culture
which shapes our political opinions and
which is shaped by the content we
consume
for a long time conservatives have ceded
creative ground to the left
it has resulted in a culture that
dictates political correctness
over freedom of thought so we are
pushing back against cultural
blacklisting on friday
january 15th daily wire is releasing its
first feature film
run hide fight this will be exclusive to
daily wire members run hide fight
is not particularly political but it is
intense
it's got a powerful message the movie
follows a high school sieged by a
quartet
of school shooters when one young girl
17 year old zoe hull
uses her wits and survival skills to
fight back
to mark the release we will be doing a
live stream premiere the night before
on thursday january 14th during a
special episode of backstage
featuring jeremy boring ben shapiro and
special guests come join us as we put
the culture back on our own terms head
to dailywire.com we'll be right
back with the mailbag
all right first question from doug
michael i'm relieved that every single
republican including the president has
condemned the violence
when do you think that democrats will
finally condemn the violence from antifa
and blm
also how long until these riots are used
to push gun control things
before they're used to push gun control
they're going to be used to push speech
control
and they already are and they're they're
censoring the president you will never
hear the media condemn the blm riots
this is something that really bugs me a
little bit
about the right i guess it's sort of to
our credit
that we'll we'll call it straight and
we'll say yeah right at capital very bad
uh blm also very bad you'll never
you'll never hear that kind of fairness
from the left what gets me though and
some conservatives are guilty of this
they'll go on and on about they'll say
oh my gosh the capital no
it's you know the worst thing that we've
ever seen it was very bad
no question about that but we're not
going to get credit from the left
certainly for condemning it uh it's it's
right
just to tell the truth and say you know
this is good and this is bad
but we're not going to get credit from
from the left no matter how much we
plead
and it's important to put things in
perspective it's kind of why i'm
defending
what a baptism today not real what a
baptism but the
context and the pointing out of
hypocrisy that people call what about
ism
any discussion of what happened at the
capitol
without a reference to black lives
matter is is
frankly dishonest and i think
conservatives
uh ought to wake up to that from brian
what would be the media narrative right
now if the election went the other way
and that was an unarmed black male
climbing through that window who was
shot and killed instead of this
this woman ashley babbitt could you even
imagine
first of all if the
election had gone the other way there
obviously would be
much much much much much more widespread
left-wing violence
just look at the cities before the
election cities boarded up
their windows why did they do that why
did los angeles board up its windows
why did new york board up its windows
why did dc board up its windows
did they do it because of all those
trump supporters in those extremely
left-wing cities
did they do it because they thought
trump supporters were going to riot and
loot the
shops no they did it because they knew
what blm would do because they'd been
doing it for six weeks six months rather
and what antifa would do they've been
doing it longer than six months
so no question about that same is true
of of the the woman who was killed
very very sad that this woman was killed
ashley babbitt
this is why you don't you don't ride in
the capitol i mean this you know you're
putting yourself in a dangerous
situation
and i suspect a lot of people who were
there thought well look these police
went so easy on blm
there's no way that they would go
harsher on us
i don't know about that but i do know if
you have somebody like
george floyd who you know he's got a rap
sheet
what a decade long or something and he
is
truly present i mean he is presented as
the symbol and the martyr of the blm
movement now
or even somebody like jacob blake jacob
blake is there's just
you know at least with george floyd you
can say well maybe the police officer
should have gotten up sooner and maybe
he wasn't
taking and maybe the whole situation was
a little strange jacob blake it's like
an open and shut case
the guy was refusing a rest the cop the
cops were called
because he was allegedly sexually
assaulting this woman
he walks out he won't surrender he's
getting tased he keeps walking and he
reaches for a knife
on the cops and finally they shoot him
and even he is
he's called an unarmed black man and an
act of unjustice by
active injustice rather by the
washington post you're still seeing this
kind of nonsense so of course
of course it's uh certainly i guess
you'd say it's a double standard but
it's
that's not what the what the left would
probably just say is
what herbert marcuza wrote in the 1960s
he's
called the father of the new left he
wrote an essay called repressive
tolerance
and he was very honest he said
liberating tolerance means
that we need to censor the right and we
need to encourage speech on the left and
i think that's what they would believe
and that's not
not exactly hypocrisy so much as
hierarchy
as uh the law professor adrian vermeuel
would sometimes say
it's hierarchy and uh you know marcus
was very honest about it
i actually sort of think if you want to
fight back against
leftist politics political correctness
woke-ism cancel culture use whatever
term you want
you you actually would do very well to
read these left-wing intellectuals i
think they actually understand this sort
of stuff
speech censorship politics i think they
understand it a lot better than the
write does
we should maybe take some notes from
nick hey michael my grandpa is a
lifelong conservative has consistently
listened to rush limbaugh for 30 years
great he is convinced there is no saving
the u.s now
that biden harris have seemingly won how
do we young conservatives
give hope to our elder conservatives who
have lost hope
or is hope lost you know a great priest
friend of mine
has this famous saying where he says the
difference between a scottish
optimist and a scottish pessimist is
that a
scottish pessimist says things can't get
any worse
and a scottish optimist says oh yes they
can
and i think conservatives are kind of
like this too you know
conservatives know that things are going
to get
much much worse and there's it kind of
cuts away at this distinction optimistic
and pessimistic
there's hope but our hope ultimately
is not in this world our hope ultimately
is in the next world we know how this
world's going to end it's not going to
look
all that pleasant in the final days okay
so
our hope is in the next world now that
doesn't mean we should throw up our
hands and throw in the towel in this
world
we should use our courage use our
patience
use our grit use our understanding of
justice and
all the other virtues and you know try
to try to make this world better
try to do the right thing but we should
know we are not going to have utopia on
earth
ain't going to happen the great
conservative consolation of course is
that reality reasserts itself in the end
and so no matter how insane things get
you know eventually utopias have to
crack
because utopias are no place that's what
it means but it can take a very long
time it can take many lifetimes and so
we're going to have to fight back but
but
for your grandpa i would just i would
say put your hope in the knowledge that
politics is going to get a lot worse
then it's going to get better and it's
going to go worse again and it's going
to get better and our ultimate hope is
uh
somewhere else from jake if you could
zip recruit
one of the daily wire employees who work
on your show who would it be
and by zip recruit i assume you mean
fire i guess
it would have to be um kind of hurts me
to say this but i guess it would have to
be jason campbell
uh jason campbell he's a good intern
he's a good publicist
but jason he writes some mean stuff
about me on like the media matters
website
and and twitter and stuff like that so i
guess prop
just to you know protect the show i
guess very sadly i would have to
zip recruit jason from sarah hi michael
given the new energy on the democratic
side of the island the complete control
of the government from the left
which american freedom will come under
attack first freedom of speech
second amendment religion et cetera well
i did already answer this a little bit i
said freedom of speech
it's currently like right this very
second is coming under attack
freedom of religion of course has
already been under attack for a long
time
and this year in particular the idea
that you could go to a pot shop a head
shop because
it was an essential service in los
angeles but you couldn't go to church
is a reflection of that
social inversion and it's not even by
the way
necessarily an abridgement of freedom of
religion
so much as a shifting of the religious
standards
because for the left
going to the head shop and buying some
really really
high quality medicinal stuff is
a sort of religious matter you know
cardinal manning has this great line
which is that all
politics all human conflict is
ultimately theological
i think that's true we always hear all
these kind of different expressions on
this point politics is downstream of
culture you know culture is downstream
of religion because cult and culture
come from the same root word
sure however you want to say it at the
root of these things
are religious differences if you really
believe that
we are just meat puppets we're meat
sacks our purpose on this life
is to get as much pleasure as we
possibly can and the purpose of politics
is to make sure that the greatest number
of people can get the most pleasure
most of the time then you're gonna have
that is a religious view and you're
gonna have a very different society
than if you have the sort of society
that we were founded as which is
broadly speaking a christian society
uh so that's already under attack that's
been under attack for a very very
long time it's almost certainly going to
get worse from dekk
hey michael i'm a big fan of the show
and all the daily wires content
i'm becoming disillusioned from the
republican party in recent months and
after the riot at capitol hill
i'm not sure where to put myself i found
the riot to be disgusting but i also
find it very hypocritical
that everyone is acting like it's the
worst thing that's ever happened in
america
after a summer of riots i'm becoming
less of a trump fan with him not
conceding
but although he did just concede so
maybe you would change that view now but
i also do not believe this was a fair
election fair enough
i don't see trump being the leader of
the party anymore but i
don't want to go back to the old
establishment types either where do you
see the party going
oh is that all you want to know i think
a lot of people agree with you i think
the vast vast vast majority of
conservatives agree with you
we don't like what happened at the
capitol that was very bad
we think it's preposterous that it's
being called pearl harbor
part two when no one's making mention of
the summer of burning down the country
we like trump a lot we think he's a lot
better than the gop establishment
he's not a perfect guy and he's made
some mistakes and had some
self-inflicted
wounds and that's very unfortunate so
what
happens now
well all i will say is it's too early to
predict who the president
or the presidential nominee is going to
be in four years trump could run again
he sort of signaled that he might
however one thing to look to i think is
who who are the media going after
right now who is big tech going after
right now
who is simon schuster going after right
now guys like holly
guys like cruz guys like ron desantis
you're noticing a sort of training of
the left-wing
scopes on them right now all the attacks
are coming at them you're not seeing
many attacks on mitt romney
well of course not mitt romney marched
with black lives matter and now he's
getting out there and lecturing all
those republicans
and all those trump supporters lecturing
his colleagues in the senate
mitt romney has affiliated with a far
more violent far more radical far more
anti-american group
than anything we've seen in recent weeks
and yet
he's going to get the credit as the
adult in the room the really
important serious republican
the future is not him the future never
was that guy that guy is a joke
the future is going to be the guys and
you who
who you can tell by their enemies who
you can tell by the people going after
them
who who is it going to be in particular
i can't i couldn't tell you that it's
just so early would you have picked
donald trump in 2012
very few people would have done that but
i do think that's going to be
the principle by which we're going to
figure out who it is from bryce
hey michael i'm in rcia right of
catholic initiation for adults
preparing to be baptized this easter
season thanks in no small part to you
and matt
my question is if the jesuits are the
order that tends toward
the liberal side of the church is there
an order of priests
that is the ultra-conservative side of
the church i want to help build
orthodoxy in the faith
what can i do as a member of the lady
love the show thanks you know it's too
bad the jesuits used to be pretty good
and then
a lot in recent years a lot
of the more prominent kooky
types of priests have been jesuits very
jesuitical
so some great well first you got to
check out the
priestly fraternity of saint peter fssp
very conservative wonderful organization
uh
they are such terrific defenders of the
traditional latin mass
brilliant priests uh i just really you
know can't speak highly enough i've
always enjoyed going to fssp
parishes there are other good ones
you'll find some good dominicans here
there you'll find some
all sorts of different different orders
you can also look for individual priests
many many who recommend themselves
i'd recommend checking out crisis
magazine it's good good to find some
good priests there where else a number
of other places
uh however um
you know this catholicism is an enacted
enfleshed sacramental religion and so so
much of it is about
the liturgy so much of it is about
accessing the sacraments
and it's hard to beat the beauty and the
seriousness with in the reverence with
which
the fssp treat that okay final question
andrew says hey michael i'm thinking
about creating a screen print for my car
15 days to slow the spread but crossing
it out with the number
to make it 297 which is today what are
your thoughts
well buddy you better make sure that
it's a dry erase wrap because that
number is going to go up and up and up
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021. today on the
ben shapiro show president trump
acknowledges his defeat and pledges a
peaceful transition of power and joe
biden and como harris they completely
destroy
any possibility of unity just right away
tune into ben shapiro show today